do you mean clop yes all right we're
gonna have to make a pancake today in
ten minutes all the way from scratch
three people from the office are gonna
judge our pancakes a winner will be
crowned and so the winner gets a $50
gift card so I have I consider myself to
be the ultimate pancake queen because I
make really fluffy thick pancakes at
home I grew up making pancakes every
Saturday on Sunday morning having to
make pancakes in ten minutes is a
challenge because I take a long time
making my pancakes I separate the wet
ingredients and the dry ingredients I
don't know how it's gonna turn out I'm
gonna I'm gonna lie it seems impossible
but if I have a strategy before I get to
everything I should be able to rock it
out I don't even know what how much I'm
gonna put in here and I also don't have
like a measuring spoon so I'm trying to
guesstimate dry ingredients are the most
important part then I'm gonna crack egg
start whisking that my milk oh wait just
kidding I need my bacon I'm gonna go for
the milk and I'm just gonna put in a
little bit at a time
I won't summer yo no singing Bianca
concentrate still pretty thick there's
still some lumps this is a rather
[ __ ] pancake I gotta make sure these
are not lumpy because if this lumpy when
it hits the skillet I'm sorry it's a
wrap oh my vanilla guys because I have
forgotten love in them that would have
been an epic fail starting to get pretty
battery this looks ready to go no I felt
like I need more something I'm going to
use some butter look this time frame is
like that me going my first pancake
always is trash I'm hoping it turns out
kind of decent though because I don't
have the time to mess up my first
pancake like I usually do at home no
that's not looking good I feel like I
need more flour while this is happening
I'm
cut up some bacon there you go give me
something yes now that looks about right
I'm watching this pancake to try and
figure out when it bubbles when it
starts to bubble I'm going to flip it
because then I know it's basically
cooked up on one side we don't cancel
that first pancake that pancake does not
count we're gonna drop some blueberries
this is starting to look kind of bubbly
I am gonna just flip it looks kind of
gross but it's okay hopefully it tastes
all right even when you feel like you
fail you just keep going now this is
always the hard part this is the first
pancake I could never tell when it's
fully picked at the bottom so I just
kind of touch it and take a look yeah it
looks good one done my presentation is
gonna be way look at that I'm ashamed
I'm still in it to win it and these
pancakes are probably gonna taste this
heirloom I don't know how much time I
have left
[ __ ] I'm gonna turn up the heat a bit
and I'm gonna panic a little bit and I'm
gonna drop some bacon in here look at
this pancake like what I'm just gonna
lead that there I'm just gonna keep
going this pancake looks like it's doing
its thing I think I might be able to
pull this off these actually don't look
too bad oh these look good okay here we
go I am making this Elvis style so I am
putting peanut butter on this drop these
bananas on more bacon bits
oh he sorry woman okay that's it I have
some time so I'm gonna add a little more
brown sugar to this I don't have much
time no thing else to do I don't know oh
yes we need syrup is our pancakes
[Music]
I hate my life right now and now we have
some syrup and that's that I'm done
hopefully they're the best 10 minute
pancakes anyone's ever had that's all we
can hope for here I don't know I haven't
tried them myself first of all is like
cows you know basically peanut butter
with a side of pancake this is bacon son
the time you have to get banana oh good
the peanut butter is surprisingly not
that overpowering the fluffiness is like
a hot point I'm point what do you guys
it looks scary to eat I did it taste
better than a house I thought this is a
pancake thing creeps yeah crepes dead
groups I'm excited about the four
strawberries I love yeah it's pretty
it's a pop of color let's go for it he's
actually looking really for good now
that they're on my floor that's the good
the blueberries I like the fruit theme
they have I'm definitely gonna have to
go with the second one is this anyone's
right I have to go with the second it
felt less filling this one's the lighter
yeah another one was super Harding but
this one is perfect guys a little Sunday
brunch are the words I tasted yours off
the girl and it was so delicious I were
like getting dry and they were doused in
peanut butter and maple syrup I like
peanut butter who doesn't love peanut
butter and maple syrup usually when I
like cook anything I take my time with a
I set up my measurements having the time
crunch was played with my head a little
bit but I had a blast it was fun is
really something you just kind of like
go with it and just let loose and even
when you feel like you're failing you
have to keep going because you have to
present something she wanted four tapes
man that's huge
[Music]